experts tell us
defense wins championships
but the offense has other ideas
in super bowl 49
they finally need to settle the score
the biggest game in all of sports
everything is set for the super bowl
matchup
isn't enough
but it doesn't stop the arguments
it's brady looking long rob gronkowski
hauls it in touchdown new england
patriots in an instant everything can
change
the defense gets another zap they will
bring the pressure
under fire on that throw intercepted
earl thomas might be the fastest safety
in the nfl and look out there he is nice
interception confidence is contagious
and a catalyst for action
and so strong stay in control
or get caught on an island there's a
reason they caught the grievous island
tom brady in the clutch
unstoppable so it's third goal can they
call a play the defense hasn't seen and
in the end
hours of hard work are defined by a
single moment
a foot race to the end zone
only one man to beat
and he's got the touchdown just
incredible a moment
it makes them think again the new
england patriots have won the super bowl
and the lombardi trophy is going back to
foxborough